the biggest trend is from human
resources to
people right just not looking as as
humans as
resources but looking at them as a
complete human being
with uh emotions and lives and and
desires and
you know experiences and and all of that
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech welcome to another episode of 20
minute leaders i am honored to be joined
today by tommy gulan the chief people
officer of visible
we're going to be talking not about
human resources but
about humans tommy's expertise is in
driving change and supporting
organizations through massive growth and
transformation
by partnering with leaders teams and
employees to think through business
problems and collaboratively move the
business forward
tommy golan welcome all the way from the
bizabo offices in new york how are you
today
i'm amazing thank you so much for having
me no no thank you for joining me i'm
excited to be talking about people
understanding what it means to be chief
people officer this is not the first
organization here the chief
people officer of i know the chief
technology officer i know the chief
executive officer chief business officer
but this is the i i believe the first
time that i have
the chief people officer of a hyper
growth
startup more than 300 people and so
um let's start with you tell me what is
chief people officer
and how do you find yourself in a role
like this
well so first of all i'm honored to feed
the to be the first chief people officer
um here very exciting um chief people
officer is really the fi the way i see
that function we have two
two sides to it one um is to be an
executive and a business partner to you
know the executive leadership team of
the company and help
take the strategy understand the
strategy and define that or build around
it
people centered
processes procedures programs
that's the first role the second role or
the second side of the role is to really
take care of everything that's people
anything from
hiring to you know benefits and
compensation
training learning and development
you know fun activities welfare
office environment so anything and
everything that touches people
in the organization i consider part of
the chief people officers
responsibility and so as you think
through these responsibilities which are
very which are very wide right so
you're mentioning a lot of different
responsibilities that are touching both
the personal and professional aspects of
the people
how how does how does the chief people
officer
interact within a high-tech organization
so
how do you fit into this you know
ecosystem of a startup
right so again i i think that um
you know our function the people
function is is a
first of all we're a service
organization so we're not defining the
strategy necessarily we're involved in
it we need to understand
it deeply but we're not defining it we
need to understand the market that we're
operating in we need to understand
the competition we need to understand
our value proposition and go to market
strategy and
all of those different pieces and then
um
collaborate very very closely with
everybody across the company if it's the
department heads and it's a very
different type of
relationship and collaboration and value
that we bring to a chief
you know chief technology officer or to
a chief revenue officer to the ceo of
the company
and our job is to really help
build facilitate promote solve problems
um with all of the people aspects that
are relevant to each one of those
different functions so
i think what's fascinating for me in
being in this role and why i'm so
passionate about it is because
it's from my perspective the only role
in the company with the exception of the
ceo
that has the full broad perspective of
everything and anything that's going on
in an organization
and we have the opportunity to really um
have a big impact on it if we do our job
right and if we support people where
they are
we have the ability to really drive an
organization forward and that's why i'm
so passionate because at the end
technology is important and nice
but without the people it doesn't mean a
whole lot so um
that's how i view this role and so
you've been in this role for for quite
some time and in different organizations
was it always obvious to you that this
is you know this is your destiny and
this is something that you want to be
doing
where what was sort of the aha moment
for you that he said this you know this
is what i want to be doing
yeah you know it's a it's an interesting
question and i keep talking about it
recently when i start
at this point in my career working with
some hr professionals that are younger
in their
profession and and you know and and just
people looking for
you know the right role for them but for
me growing up i for sure was going to be
a doctor that was the only thing i
wanted to do when i grow up
um and um you know i studied
biology physics all of those important
things and then you know after the army
when i
time came to actually go to school i
figured not gonna spend seven years this
is crazy
so completely pivoted my whole focus to
uh psychology i've always been very
passionate about
about people and trying to understand
people so started
psychology studied some criminology and
then ended up in business school when i
moved here to the us
and one of my professors at the time in
barylan university in israel told me
that i have a very interesting a very
good business mind and i should probably
explore that so i
went to business school from you know
from i don't know how i ended up there
but i did loved it fell in love with
just the business world
um and i definitely did not want to do
hr that was very very clear to me at the
time i was working in finance
and then i went to graduate school and i
started organizational psychology
because i was fascinated by the dynamics
in an organization
but definitely did not want to be hr i
left school and i went to do consulting
which is what i thought it was going to
do and then one of my
customers and good friends asked me to
come in as their hr
you know first hr person here in the us
and reluctantly i said yes but then when
i actually stepped
into the organization and understood how
powerful this position is and what it
should be and at the time
not dating myself too much but at the
time
hr was a very very administrative
tactical role in most organizations
but i knew and i felt that there was
something more that needs to be
needs to be unleashed you know when it
comes to
working with people in an organization
and that's really been my passion that
was my aha moment when i was actually in
there
and i was very fortunate to work with an
incredible leader and you know
was given the the space and the ability
to do things a little bit differently
i really understood the power and the
impact of this role and since then i've
been doing a combination of
in-house and consultancy but always on
the people's side and operations because
that's really my passion the building
and
and understanding and organization and
creating programs that can help drive
value and create um and drive the
organization forward that's really
what gets me excited every morning
that's why i wake up
amazing and so take me you know 30 000
feet in the air
and you know what have we been observing
in the human resources
space because you know what i'm
experiencing as a young entrepreneur and
as an engineer
and i'm watching you know a lot of my
friends going through hiring processes
and
and i'm watching things change and they
you know both
the the relationships are changing the i
guess the power dynamics are changing
from the hr perspective on a scale level
what greater trends have you been
observing over the last i don't know
two three five years yeah yeah so the
biggest trend is from
human resources to people right just
not looking as as humans as resources
but looking at them as a complete human
being
with uh emotions and lives and and
desires and
you know experiences and and all of that
that's the biggest shift that happened
from when i started in this profession a
very long time ago
um to what it is today over the last
year and a half a huge shift in the
world in general because of this
pandemic
and one of the i mean it's a it's a
horrible
period and a lot of very negative things
happen at that time but one of the good
things that happened at that time
is that the whole dynamic changed in
organizations and
literally one morning everybody changed
the way they work
because we had no other choice and since
then
i think people and organizations
understood finally because we in the hr
profession have been talking about it
for a very long time that being in an
office every day nine to five
didn't make sense for a very very long
time that's not what people need that's
how not how
humans operate today with technology
with the ability to stay connected all
the time um
certainly the younger generations who
are looking for more
um you know they're looking for more
flexibility and they have a lot of
different interests and work is no
longer
the only thing in the center of their
lives um
it's been there for a very long time
we've been talking about it and
preaching it for a very long time but
then
literally one morning it just happened
and you know when people understood that
one people can operate from anywhere
really because we have the technology we
have the way to do it
people generally and if you don't hire
people like that then you're doing
something wrong but they're independent
and they're passionate and they want to
be successful
and you don't have to see them next to
you in an office necessarily in order
for them to do their job
all of a sudden there's a huge shift in
in how
employees look at the workplace and how
organizations companies look at look at
humans within that workspace so the last
year and a half have been
the most fascinating in my career from
that perspective
and i think there's a lot more a lot
more to come now that you're trying to
figure out what's the future of work
what does hybrid even mean um and what
actually works what
you know where people are really truly
the most productive is it
only at home it's only in the office
it's the combination there's a lot of
unknowns and a lot of
things that are being looked at and
tested right now which will
yield some some amazing fascinating
results
so it sounds to me that this is a pretty
confusing time for a lot of people in
the
in the pip in the people business on the
side of companies right because you know
the
in terms of technology things are moving
along as expected in terms of
you know venture capital and investments
and vision of companies you have the ceo
for that but all of a sudden your
position
as the chief people officer your job has
completely changed over the last year
and a half
or at least tactically speaking the way
that you're operating your job on a
day-to-day basis right
yeah i think what the biggest shift that
happened which is amazing for this
profession
is that all of a sudden one morning it
just became such an important role right
there's a lot of i'm very fortunate that
i worked with
very um i would say progressive
open-minded amazing leaders and ceos
that really
allowed me to to show the value and and
and and change things and do things a
little bit differently as i mentioned
before
but a lot of a lot of hr professionals
you know for many
many many years we're not doing that
we're not allowed and then one morning
the organization woke up in a big crisis
when everybody needs to work remote with
no technology no infrastructure no
policies no communication
and a lot of very confused employees and
everybody all of a sudden turned
to their hr person to solve all of these
issues
um and a lot of people were not equipped
for that a lot of people did not know
how to deal with it so there was a lot
of confusion
um you know there's there's a big strong
community of hr professionals and we
helped and and everybody was helping
each other to try and navigate
this crazy crazy period but i always
thought and i've again
was fortunate enough to work in
organization that really put people in
the center
um and and for us it was for
from myself and my team was a pretty
seamless
you know uh transition to to virtual and
remote we just shifted how we do
onboarding and how we train and how we
communicate and you know it was it
wasn't easy but it was pretty seamless
because
everything was already there but a lot
of organizations literally had nothing
there
and the hr professional needed to really
figure everything out
you know figure out all of those
different motions that are critical to
be able to work remotely so
um a big shift for this profession is
just fine now finally you know
really people understand the value of
having somebody in this role thinking
about
all of these issues and and helping
advance the organization forward it's
it's incredible amazing and i think that
you know
it's it's so weird thinking about you
know the
you know now i'm trying to put myself in
your position and you're waking up and
you're understanding that
you know measuring people's expectations
the norms have changed it's not really
clear what the norms really are
so just even thinking of how to ask
these questions and obviously with every
company having different culture you're
going to have different expectations for
different groups of people of whether
they come back to the office or how they
how where
what are their now communication
expectations obviously we can see behind
me my dog is taking apart my nintendo
which is completely fine because this is
this is much more interesting for me
right now and i wanna
i wanna pick your brain on you know
looking forward to the next few years
and you know even the next
year you know usually when i talk about
industries i'm thinking five years down
the line here i'm thinking
six months down the line a year down the
line what are some of the bigger
challenges that
chief people officers around companies
you know
if more than 300 people there's a lot of
responsibility what are some of the
challenges that are being presented
right now and how are you tackling those
yeah so i you know in it depends on the
company the stage and what's going on
right now there's a lot of companies who
are still trying to recover you know
from what the impact of the pandemic
there are companies like visible
which i'm you know excited to be part of
today that
uh went to a very meaningful pivot and
started to grow very very fast and
doubling our size so very different
challenges and different issues for
different types of companies where they
are
i think there's a few um a few things
that we're all i think
sharing right now in what we're dealing
with one the market is the market is
very hot there's a lot of money in the
market
everybody's hiring the competition on
talent is fierce
um in many many locations for us
specifically we're in israel
new york in israel tel aviv new york and
kiev
in the ukraine and all of those markets
are going through
an unbelievable hype and and it feels
like the bubble
um kind of happening all over again so
um hiring retention um very challenging
right now
um reinventing what the workplace needs
to be is something that we're investing
an enormous amount of time
um in we're doing a lot of internal
surveys we're talking to a lot of
different companies we're
studying from others who have made some
bold decisions and
and understand what the outcomes of
those decisions are
um i personally love to stay very
connected to our employees and really
meet them where they are
right now we have people in the office
they're excited to come to the office we
didn't tell anyone to come to the office
uh but here people really see the value
of the in person and just
getting back to to those interactions
and solving problems by turning to
somebody
you know sitting next to you in two
minutes versus scheduling yet another
30-minute zoom call so
naturally and organically it's just
happening but what the future looks like
is a very good question
we're designing three new offices to
accommodate what we believe is the
future of work
you know in the office environment needs
to serve a very different purpose right
now
you know a lot of us are dealing with as
i mentioned expectations from employees
that are very different depending on the
stage of their career
but right now more than ever employees
are looking at companies to solve
all of the problems you know they're
looking at us to solve
not just business problems and and you
know they're looking at
solutions for mental health and physical
health health and emotional life and
work-life balance and
you know social justice and a lot of
different things that were not part of
the working world
um up until fairly recently um and
that's a big change and why do you draw
the line and what's your role as an
employer is something that we're all
trying to figure out so
a lot of different uh very big changes
and movements that are happening right
now and
the way i i tackle it is again by
learning and and being open-minded
and speaking to our employees constantly
if it's surveys
if it's conversations one-on-one with
managers directors globally
to understand the different culture
nuances and um
that's the best way and we look at this
period right now as we call it beta
testing so
we're opening the offices whoever wants
to come come we keep talking to people
making some changes and testing the
water to see what resonates what doesn't
um and again meet people where they are
to make sure that we they do the best
work in the best way possible
and remain engaged and happy and
productive that's really the the main
goal here
amazing amazing i have so many more
questions you know i think we can do a
whole other episode just thinking about
what responsibilities then does this
leave to the ceo and the cto to work
with the chief people officer
and to to to enable them to to grow and
to even ask
these difficult questions and and it
sounds like you know
one aspect here that is that is new is
here is that you know there's going to
be a lot of innovation
in your space now so you know we've seen
a lot of industries undergo a massive
change and i've been seeing a lot of
early stage companies dealing with the
future of work and productivity for
remote teams
etc and these are really things that you
know i guess you're concerned with right
now and i think that's pretty
a pretty remarkable thing to to think
through and so i'm excited to see where
where this leads all this different
innovation
i have three short questions for you
tommy and not for
the chief people officer but but you
take me back to your childhood what
really fascinated you as a kid
people sounds cheesy right but people i
was always fascinated with what makes
people tick
and even as a very young child i
remember asking my
parents very very difficult questions to
really try to understand what motivates
them so it's always been for me about
trying to figure people out
wow amazing and um somebody or something
that inspires you today so as you go
about your day as you're asking yourself
these difficult questions
where do you derive some of the
inspiration
uh my kids i have three wonderfully
amazing
daughters and they
challenge me and surprise me and inspire
me every day
i want to just be a good role model for
them
which is why what i strive to every day
um
and now that they're older um and really
can understand and appreciate up until
now when i said hr they knew what i was
doing but i had no idea what that meant
now they finally get it so they
challenge me and they represent a
different
you know different point of view which
truly inspires me every day
amazing and three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um three words passionate
curious and um
a builder amazing
tommy today thank you so much i know you
know you have a lot of work to be doing
and you're you're undergoing massive
changes and and i think it's
i just think it's exciting and you know
i'm jealous and scared of what you're
doing at the same time because i know
how
confusing it is and at the end it's um
it's it's a new industry and it's a new
market and and and i just love the open
mindedness and i love the approach of of
understanding
the complexity behind it so thank you
for taking the time to share this with
me
stay safe and stay healthy and i and i
look forward to seeing what happens with
the busable thank you
thank you so much it was a pleasure
thank you michael
[Music]